There is no correct answer for which is better, a left-handed or a right-handed
one of the other. May be more convenient for people or intelligent rabbits,
depending on a situation. One other area in computer graphics where opinions
vary is whether the y-axis or the z-axis should be on the up direction.
Architects tend to think in terms of floor plans, so the x and y-axes, our
directions on the ground, and z is then the height. However, another common way
to think about coordinate system is with respect to our display. Looking at a
monitor and starting on the lower left-hand corner, the x-axis goes to the
right, the y-axis goes up. If we want to present a right headed coordinate
system with respect to the monitor, the z-axis then points towards us. We'll see
this type of definition in a later unit where we cover how to define a camera.
The difference between these two coordinate systems is just a 90 degree rotation
along the x-axis. So, it's easy enough to fix. We'll talk about rotations in a
later unit, too. However, you've now been warned. If you read in some models
some day into your program and the object is sideways, it's probably because the
models up direction is different than what you're expecting.